Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to the Try Not to Laugh challenge.
Now I know, there's been some talk out there.
"Oh...! The try not to laugh videos. They're just Mark laughing for ten minutes straight!" (well i mean it's true)
Well hey...oww first, oww my pride and then number two.....how dare you!
*burp* (ew Mark)
I ain't gonna be...
Tolerating any of that bullshit talk anymore!
(sure)
I'm going to be doing this particular Try not to laugh and if I even crack a smile I will...
I will...
*slurps coke*
I bet again, I bet then I'm not gonna laugh! and if I do... if I do...(you will mark)
Then Tyler and Ethan can punish me again. Maybe if I crack a smile that'll be okay, but we'll play it by ear (get your punishments ready)
Okay, cool. Alright sound good? Alright. Here. We go!
*Wait - Ying Yang Twins*
Hey how you doing little momma let me whisper in your ear.
it's free real estate
*Mark trying to keep himself from laughing* (almost instant failure for the umpteenth time)
*Sightly clears throat*
...Not funny... (Suuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuure Mark)
*Eerie music*
*gunshots are replaced with Gabe the dog barking*
*Gabe barking is replaced with gunshots*
*Mark tries to restrain laughs...again*
*clears throat*
*Putin playing piano poorly*
*continued terrible piano, by Vladimir Putin*
*Mark trying to restrain laughs by making his mouth tiny*
(10/10 piano Putin)
Nope! Not funny! Not what I would call funny! Not funny!(not really funny)c
Do I wanna know what this is? (JOJO)
Hank Zeppili: "God dang it! I'm gonna kick your ass"
"With the power of my stand!"
"『Propane Nightmare!』"
*Hwat intensifies*
"Bwaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaah!"
start of video repeats* Not- ne-he- woAh HeY wOahYOu only get one turn on that now that was not funny! (Sure dude) I
'm not good at this boom thing.
DID SOME BODY SAY BOOM!?
*shigechi fucking dies*
"TOH-BLAGH"
Mmm I don't know what that was about. It's the same anime that it was just referred to but I have no idea (JJBA. Watch it.)
*roundabout starts*
It gets bigger when I pull on it ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Mmmmmmm ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
*Mark snorting a bit*
Sometimes, I pull on it so hard, I rip the skin ( ͡☉ ͜ʖ ͡☉)
Well, my daddy taught me a few things too like how not to rip the skin by using someone else's mouth, ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
'stead of your own hands ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Will you show me? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
I'd be right happy to! ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
*roundabout kicks in*
(Mark tries to conceal his laughs once again)
*Mark attempts to keep his composure* (TYLER GET THE PUNISHMENT!!!)
*clears throat*
*clears throat again*
Gween Tea
Cawffee
gween tea!
cawffee!
*In a low-pitched voice* Cawffee!
*In a high-pitched voice* Gween Tea!
*In a robo voice* Cawffee
*In an extremely distorted voice* GrEUn TEAy
Coffeeff
Greerg
Co- woru-kun! *Kaworu dies*
Gween Tea- eez
Nuts.
HA!
H H H  hAAAA
*Mark instantly snorts in an attempt to not laugh*
CawffEE
*destroyed audio* GGRegeggennnNnn TTETaTaaAAeeeE
*Mark blowing his cheeks trying not to laugh*
Coffee
Ragyo: "Satsuki..."
Co-
Karl Pilkington
Alright.
*Mark snickers*
CAAAAAWWWWWWW
Gween TeEEEEAAAAAA
Mm mm.
Nope. Not funny. I didn't laugh. That wasn't a laugh!
*Eurobeat plays as a man skyrockets to space with his trusty lawn mower*
"Play of the game"
Oh, hi Mark (MARK-CEPTION!!!!!!!!)
*Johnny starts destroying everything in his sight as "Play of the Game" music from Overwatch plays*
*snicker*
*snickers more*
Nope... Noooooot... fun-ny. NOT... fun-ny
MMMMMMMMMMMMMMMM
NOT FUNNY
*Jerma985 playing superhot laughs*
That guy just shot that other guy immediately in the face. I had nothin to do with that
There was an argument- there like a workplace argument that these Red Dudes had
*turns around to similar situation*
*wHOO*
*Lets out a small giggle mixed with a wheeze*
*short burst*
Mmh
*Gabe barks to the tune of Big Blue from F-Zero* (RIP Gabe the bork king)
Nup
It's not a soldier's gun, aye?
Not a soldier's gun!
It's high tolerances?
Not a soldier's gun...
Unreliable?! *cocks gun*
UNRELIABL- *gunshots*
(Man doesn't demonstrate good gun safety)
UN*bleep*ING RELIABLE?!
It unreliable, ladies and gents!
*more gunshots*
UN-FucKING-RELIABLE!
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
I'm so scared.... I'm so scared. (Me too.)
I know exactly what you're looking for.
What is it..?
Don't.
Is it a long, hard-( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
JJJOOOOOHHHHHNNNNN CCCCCEEEEEEENNNNNAAAAA
*old meme*
Okay.
*Roundabout starts playing*
*Mini Nuke Appears*
*roundabout picks up pace...*
*ded*
*wheeeEEEzeee laugh*
*muffled* oh no
It wasn't a real laugh! It wasn't a real one! (sure mark)
I forgot what I was doing. I got caught up in the moment, that wasn't a real laugh! Don't count that one! (JUST THIS ONE TIME)
(In Japanese) I guess it can't be helped
*seductively* "Nico nico nii~"
(same voice clip, but the pitch is changed at different parts to match the video)
*dull thump*
*sniff*
*multiple Mark groaning noises*
*Bird whistling Addam's family theme*
*whack*
*explosion*
*Addam's Family Theme Tweet*
TAP
BOOM
uggGGGHH
Nope!
nUP
nyoooOOOOOOPPPEE
*Toast soars away to x-files theme*
*loops*
Stop...
Stop.
S T O P
Try (in arabic)
Prank'd
*Guy in video laughs hysterically*
*little snort*
That one's not funny
This is a Bucket.
Dear god
There's more.
nOOOOO....
*Video replays and Mark loses it because of Soldier*
*wheezes and giggles in the background*
*Mark finally gives in completely* (aaaaaaaaaaaaaaND I'm calling Tyler)
*more laughter*
Why?! I've seen that before!
I've watched that whole video!
NOOOO!
I've seen this before.
is a bucket.
Dear god...
There's more.
nOOOOO....
*Mark continues to lose the challenge*
Why is that the one?!
WHY?! it's not even that funny!!
I've seen this before...
Dear god...
There's more.
nOOOOO....
*hearty, unrestrained laughter*
EUUUGH
I don't know!
Oh, fuck I lost...
Oh no! I lost!
Oh shit
*muffled laughter/panic/crying*
*Oblivion music*
*Kid starts clapping awkwardly*
*horrible lip sync coupled with bad, bad voice acting* Kid: "You are great. When is your violin concert?"
*Still horrible lip sync* Girl: "June 15th!"
"What's the day today?"
"June 11!"
*exceedingly awkward pause*
"Oh! This Friday?"
"Can you come to my concert?"
"Sure!"
*torment slowly winds to an end*
*Video repeats and Mark loses some more*
The fucking... walking straight up to someone *Mimics video*
Ey, that pretty good
*claps*
Not bad there.
*more awkward claps*
Hey, really doing me proud.
*Claps yet again...*
Alright, ok, I lost (not surprised here)
AgaAAAAAIN!
Ohh boy
*Dialtone*
Mark: I was recording a video, and uh...
I...
I uh... I was recording a Try Not to Laugh
And uh,
I bet that I wouldn't laugh at it.....
And I laughed
*both laughing*
I mean, not if you don't make there another punishment
*Mark bursts out laughing*
Yeah, go for it, okay...
Alright.
(Laugh cornier than a state fair)
You sound like- you sound like the Count from Sesame Street
*Mimics Tyler's laugh*
ONE!
You were right! I was wrong!
I laughed. It's my fault, so...
We'll see about that punishment later... (can't wait! >:D)
So thank you everybody so much for watching. If you enjoyed this let me know down the comments below. (I certainly enjoyed it)
Do you want to see another one let me know in the comments below as well. (ooh please)
And if you have suggestions for funny clips put those down there as well.
Thanks again, and as always. I will see you in the next video.
Buh Bye!